follow good morning ladies gentlemen I
steam room every and the act irritated
officer at the bubble action for
Warrington north him I give the number
of votes recorded for each candidate the
election was as follows
valhallen Conservative Party Canada
17700 74 James Washington UK
Independence Party 1561 Helen Jones
Labour Party 27,000 356 Stefan Christian
AK Liberal Democrats 1207 and Lindsay
McAteer Green Party 619 68 percent to 99
sport papers are hereby declare Helen
Jones is to be elected as a candidate to
be the candidate for Warrington north
[Applause]
McAfee
can I first of all thank the returning
officer the counting staff and those who
worked at polling stations for the work
that they have put in today also I'd
like to thank the police for keeping us
safe in these times which are very dark
for our country I think we realize how
much we come to rely on what is an even
thinner blue line to protect us or we
are very grateful to all of you 20 years
ago when I was first elected as the MP
for Warrington North someone told the
council offices not to bother replying
to my letters because I would only be a
one-term candidate this is now my sixth
general election and the fact that I am
still here I owe to a number of people
first of all to my husband Mike who is
my agent and my son Chris who've not
only given me huge support politically
but have put up with the disruption the
scratch meals and me being away an awful
lot secondly to my wonderful staff Steve
and Dom Andrew and Morgan who sacrificed
their holidays to help in this campaign
to my great team of canvases and leaf
litters all unpaid and working seven
days a week a cart Lamy wall but
particularly David and Ian the littler
leaf litters in chief and Graham the
poster king and Jade who looked after
social media all of you have done a
splendid job lastly I would like to
thank the electors of Warrington North
who have now sent me to Parliament six
times who have displayed incredible
loyalty to me and to the Labour Party
and who are the most splendid group
of people solid reliable dependable I am
extremely grateful to them all and I
shall do my best to represent them in
Parliament as they should be represented
thank you